♪ ♪
You've taken the first step
towards gaining
control of your life.
♪ ♪
At Hugs Not Thugs,
we rehabilitate
ex-gang members.
JULIO: We offer free
legal counseling,
solar panel
installation classes.
I even got dental insurance.
Man, your teeth still look
pretty (bleep) up, though.
Yeah, but guess what?
They used to be
even more (bleep) up.
♪ ♪
My cousin spent the last
eight years in prison.
Sorry I'm late!
I'm just trying to help him.
But that fool
won't listen to me.
Why does your body
still look 19,
but your face looks 56, fool?
♪ ♪
No offense, my boy, but you
come off like a punk-ass bitch.
-Do you mind moving your car?
-Bad timing.
I think I got room.
Studies show that the life
expectancy of a gangster,
24 years old.
But the life expectancy
of a punk-ass bitch?
(tires screech)
76 years old.
I'll just go around.
Ooh.
♪ ♪
-(crash)
-(horn honks)
-Thanks, fellas.
-(bell dings)
People love buying cupcakes
from ex-gang members.
Boy, oh, boy. These sure are
some yummy cupcakes.
Bitch, do you want me
to relapse?
Why don't you buy a cupcake?
Thank you.
Red velvet is an amazing choice.
(doorbell rings)
Want to help us go fight
some fools at the park?
I can't, dawg. My sciatic
nerve's been actin' up.
-JULIO: Where's the problem?
-My L-4, L-5, dawg.
-Damn, mine's L-5 and S-1.
-Come on, y'all stay focused.
♪ ♪
JULIO:Me and Maggie just
got back together again.
Who knows how long we're
gonna be together this time.
♪ ♪
(high-pitched):
Get his ass.
♪ ♪
I'd rather die than let you
fools walk all over me.
-So just shoot me, please.
-Ooh, I'mma film this.
We don't even have guns.
♪ ♪